un sac le compagnon d'une vie dans son
atelier d'amiante des halles donne
naissance à ses partenaires du quotidien
il crée une alliance de deux matériaux
aussi noble que naturel le bois et le
cuir les deux matières sont proches le
fait de travailler récurer paix c'est un
joueur quand on travaille par exemple un
plaquage pour des bois donc un bois
plutôt fin mais ça se rejoint dans le
sens il ya un rapport pour la découpe du
cuir ça se coupe avec une lame de cutter
ce qui peut être la même chose pour
couper de voir ces du perçage c'est de
la géométrie c'est de la découpe
c'est assez naturel dans le temps vous
êtes bien des mâles en bois et en cuir
qui étaient cloués c'est une autre façon
de marier ces deux matières quand on les
touche où il ya une c'est un rapport à
la sensation à l'odorat et le fasse et
il ya ce lien là et du coup c'est à sa
part est en fait assez évident après un
ca paix menuiserie damien devient
ébéniste chez les compagnons du devoir
puis monte son entreprise quinze ans
plus tard c'est grâce à une amie qu'il
débute dans la création avec un premier
sac en 2014 une amie qui est mosaïste
qui me demande de lui fabriquer pour une
exposition un sac tout en bois et donc
je fais ce sac l incruste de la mosaïque
pour décorer donc c'est une pièce
conférence en collaboration et d'où
toute la démarche créative autour de cet
objet mali a même amené à réfléchir un
l'objet sac et du coup j'ai c'est là que
l'idée est venue de garder une partie du
bois de le remplacer par une autre
matière pour rend l'objet facile à
utiliser au quotidien
octobre 2014 l'artisan lance sa
collection quotidien pause week end
minimum des noms attribués selon la
taille de chaque objet de la coupe et la
couture tous sont créés à la main un
savoir faire qui passe aussi par le
choix des pièces n'entache sans chrome
donc le ca qui va se bâtit neil en fait
les couleurs peuvent bouger un peu dans
le temps
toujours en fait j'aime bien l'idée
qu'un objet que le fait de vieillir soit
plutôt racines d'embellissement que
l'averse et pour se démarquer il possède
sa propre signature
donc chaque sac a donc une couture bleu
blanc rouge d'une surpiqûre il a une
date de naissance du jour est déterminé
comme celui-ci il a été fait le 3
février 2010 est une confection qui a un
coût de 100 à 800 euros le sac
cela fait un an que damien des halles
est installé rue royale à versailles un
atelier boutique où sont accueillis
clients et curieux
on n'est pas forcément dans l'attende
incluant on travaille toute la journée
en fabriquant on nous voit en vitrine
il se trouve que l'espace permet
d'exposer des sacs donc les gens peuvent
venir avec plaisir mais c'est un lieu où
il n'y a pas d'horaire c'est vrai on
n'est pas commerçant mais là on est
artisan vraiment c'est vraiment c'est de
cette idée là dessus lieux les visiteurs
peuvent découvrir des créations uniques
comme ce modèle réalisé en partenariat
avec un tatoueur pour les journées
européennes des métiers d'art damien
fera des démonstrations au public